I got sober and spent the next 10 years
blindly unaware of how I had transferred
all of that addict energy into my food
choices and the relationship between
what I was eating and the emotional
state that I was in was completely
Beyond me until I kind of you know
reached a ner with it and looked at it
for the very first time and I had all
these tools and I still wasn't seeing it
I was like what do you mean I'm an
emotional eater you know but then when
you look at it you're like well oh my
God like when you do that inventory
you're like holy yeah it's
incredible and it's empowering because
you realize like oh when I feel like
this or when this is happening or I just
you know mindlessly reach for this thing
it is the self that makes those
uncomfortable emotions go away and so
when you're counseling people around
breaking up with those habits you're
asking them to divorce themselves from
what is perhaps their best friend yeah
even if they're not aware of it